good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
we're going to start our session my name
is Shakira the Under Secretary General
of the United Nations a charge of the
least developed countries landlocked
developing countries and small island
developing state ambassador epic an
ambassador Sharia dr. Jocelyn
excellencies ladies and gentlemen
members of the faculty I would like to
warmly welcome you to this academic
roundtable entitled economic growth and
structural change priorities for the LD
seas I would like to especially thank
our partners from the Development
Research Group of the World Bank and the
asia-pacific Economic Cooperation Study
Center as well as the School of
International and public affairs of
Columbia University for co organizing
this event with internationally renowned
expert who would provide us with
insights about how the least developed
countries can reach their Development
Goals through structural transformation
I would also like to convey my gratitude
to the permanent representative of
Turkey to the United Nations who
provided support to organize this event
as you are aware the fourth United
Nations conference on the least
developed countries has resulted in the
adoption of a bold political declaration
as well as a program of action very
ambitious one its overarching goal is to
address the structural handicaps of the
ELL disease therefore securing poverty
eradication and the attainment of the
International agreed Development Goals
across L disease as well as increasing
graduation of these countries from their
status of least developed countries in
this regard the Istanbul program of
action calls for a shift in a
development paradigm with a rebalancing
of priorities between the productive
sectors and the social sectors as well
as a balanced role between the state and
the market despite considerable progress
with regard to growth and achieving some
of the MDGs the least developed
countries are still characterized by
high vulnerabilities to external shocks
these include economic shocks like
volatile commodity prices due to their
limited diversification of production
and export as well as increasing food
prices due to the relatively low
agricultural productivity thus the first
priority area for action of the Istanbul
programme of action focuses on
productive capacity to bring about
structural transformation it has the
ultimate goal to increase decent
employment which is the only sustainable
way to reduce poverty and promoting this
agenda requires focused action in key
areas
with emphasis on the state in promoting
change mobilizing resources expanding
trade opportunities the Istanbul program
of action also broadened the partnership
for LD seas
not only with the development partners
or traditional development partners
including south-south cooperation but
also with other relevant stakeholders
especially the Istanbul programme of
action calls for a great role and
contribution of actors such as
parliament private sector and civil
society in the implementation monitoring
and follow-up and review of the
programme of action the notion of
partnership with civil society includes
of course academia and philanthropic
foundations the report of the
secretary-general on the outcome of the
Istanbul conference stayed that for the
effective and efficient implementation
of the priority actions of the Istanbul
programme of action it is necessary to
take into account recent research
findings and best practices thus
academia including universities and
research institutions should be invited
to generate up-to-date information that
can facilitate policy discussions and
advice for evidence-based
decision-making it is in that context
that we have organized this academic
round table to learn about most recent
research findings from our experts and
to facilitate dialogue between the
different groups of stakeholders of the
Istanbul programme of action thus I'm
glad that we have not only government
representative
here and academia in the audience today
but also representatives from civil
society and private sector I would like
to also draw your attention that we also
have media with us which is one of the
powerful tools to carry forward our
message the objective of this roundtable
is to discuss policy recommendations on
how the least developed countries can
overcome economic vulnerabilities and
better manage risk in order to achieve
sustained equitable inclusive economic
growth the roundtable is expected to
contribute to the identification of
strategies required in order to
implement the Istanbul programme of
action before we hear from the keynote
speak AB speaker mr. Justin Lin chief
economist and senior vice president of
the World Bank the permanent
representative of Turkey ambassador a
pecan representing the host country of
the Istanbul conference and ambassador
Acharya of Nepal chair of the group of
the least developed countries will make
short remarks after the keynote speak on
challenges opportunities and strategies
for structural transformation in the
least developed countries there would be
a panel discussion featuring foundation
futuring friendly luce executive
secretary executive secretary of the
african capacity building foundation
Allianz Duque nama Andrew gleans
professor of economics at University of
Massachusetts at Helms's and Aditya
Matsu research managers at word Bank
their presentation will focus on the
role of resources employment and growth
enhancing trade and will be followed by
an interactive discussion thank you for
attending this session
and thank you for your kind attention
I have to call on ambassador a chair
ambassador a pecan of Turkey to make his
brief introductory remarks
ladies and gentlemen I would like to
thank undersecretary shake city the
other and his team for organizing this
significant event and for their kind
invitation my thanks also go to to the
Columbia University Columbia University
and also to the World Bank for their
important contributions
which to other countries are important
members of the international community
their economic growth and sustainable
development is vital to the world's
welfare peace and stability the
development process of these countries
poses a major challenge for themselves
as well as for their development
patterns but investing in a disease is
an opportunity for all as they have huge
untapped potential
the fourth United Nations conference on
a disease held in Istanbul last May gave
a strategic focus on the complex issues
of their disease the outcome document of
the conference namely the Istanbul
programme of action put forward the
parameters of a renewed and strengthened
global partnership for the development
of a disease over the next 10 years
Istanbul programme of action declares
that the ownership and primary
responsibility for development lies with
their disease themselves it also covers
the pledges of development partners to
an accelerated an inclusive economic and
social development in their disease in
addition to the Brussels program of
action of 2000 of the year 2000 which
focused more on trade issues Istanbul
programme of action put an emphasis on
increasing the productive capacities and
investments it underscores the critical
importance of infrastructure and Science
and Technology in development the
document seeks to address vital concerns
on many areas thus the core elements of
the example programme of action are more
than Oda commitments which are also
vital for the development of a disease
besides the programme of action
emphasizes good governance that includes
democracy respect for human rights role
love equity transparency and
inclusiveness by the program affection
that our decision the development
partners committed to collaborate on
among others such as enhancing financial
and technical support to productive
capacity development and diversification
of economies increasing investments and
creating new jobs promoting foreign
direct investments in their disease
through creating specific incentives to
and partnership with the business
community building resilience to
economic natural and environmental shops
establishing a science technology and
innovation center for and or a
technology bank for their disease indeed
these are mostly the novelties put out
by the Istanbul program of action and
their implementation necessitates
structural transformation now the full
and effective implementation of Istanbul
programme of action is the major
undertaking of the international
community it's a challenge but a great
opportunity at the same time as an
initial step towards time the
implementation of that program of action
is integration international policies
cooperation frameworks as well as
relevant international processes remains
critical than concrete actions to
respond to the challenges of a disease
can be identified and realized it's also
crucial to set targets indicators and
timetables in the implementation the
upcoming Rio +20 sustainable development
conference is a milestone in a series of
major UN conferences a global
sustainable development issues are tried
to be addressed at the Rio +20 process
questions related to a disease must be
taken into consideration all that is
contained in the Istanbul
program affection should be mainstream
into the outcome document of the Rio +20
conference finally taking into
consideration the business's usual
approach to policymaking is not
sufficient to place their disease on the
path of more dynamic and inclusive
development the international community
should make all possible efforts to
contribute effective implementation of
the Istanbul programme of action thank
you for your attention i i thank
ambassador epic on for his statement now
i have the pleasure to give the floor to
his Excellency Acharya permanent
representative of Nepal to the United
Nations under secretary-general Diarra
dr. Justin nepheline ambassador pecan
distinguished members of the academia
and colleagues first of all I'd like to
thank World Bank as well as the Columbia
University for organizing this very
important program I think my colleagues
both ambassador DRI as well as a master
pecan have said about the Istanbul
program faction so I don't want to you
know go into the details of that but I
just would like to say a couple of
points the one is what we are really
trying to see is that you know the LD
C's are first of all 48 countries the
least developed countries in terms of
human development in terms of the income
growth and in terms of the high
vulnerability to the shocks whether its
internal or external this is what makes
all these you know 48 countries which
are at the bottom of the development
ladder their problem becomes a very
serious issue for the international
community not only for themselves we are
talking about a 900 million people who
live there in around that country and
there are 33 countries in Africa 14 in
Asia and one in the Western Hemisphere
that is Haiti so you see the this
level of human development low level of
increments so to say poverty trap and
the high level of vulnerability - all of
us together so our challenge therefore
was to have a conference not only have a
conference but to come out with a
strategy that will take into account in
a comprehensive manner the development
challenges of LD she's so Istanbul
conference from that perspective was
very important the reason was that
although we live in a very globalized
world the fate of 900 million people is
something which we have to take very
seriously if we are talking about a
global peace if we are talking about you
know the issue of poverty at the global
level from moral and ethical perspective
so it is important from the ethical
perspective and more possible equally
important is that it is important for
international peace and security as well
as a self-interest if we are talking
about economic growth around the world I
think that must include about a billion
people that we are talking about and
therefore I think what we were also
saying is that globalization has
provided us with both opportunity but as
well a challenges therefore
marginalization of a such a large number
of people in a kind of a trap in which
they are in requires of course the
support and the proactive approach from
the countries themselves because first
of all it is the country themselves we
have to make an effort but equally
important in today's globalized world is
that that has to have very strong
international support for them and when
we say international support yes Oda is
important if you look at the overall
structural challenges of the LDCs if
there is no resources
there will be no investment if there is
no investment that is not going to be a
growth therefore we are saying that OD
is very important but equally important
we say is that trade and investment are
really critical now these are the
driving factors these days and all they
have to do it is that they should have a
coherence that whatever we're trying to
do with Oda should not be undermined by
whatever we're trying to do at the
International Trading regime equally in
fact whatever we're trying to do within
these areas should not be undermined by
international investment
as well that's why all these three
things are four things including science
and technology must help us enhance our
capacity to do more I think this is
precisely what we have agreed in this
tumbler conference of course the details
are there good governance is important
finance it is important rule of law is
important and our own winners ship and
leadership of the entire development
process are all really very very
important but what we really therefore
try to see there in Istanbul was that
there has to be a mutual compact and
this mutual compact has to be based on
international solidarity and partnership
and we are today therefore we really
like to hear that how the structural
change in our countries can really bring
about change in the lives of the people
on a sustainable basis I think equity is
very important sustainability of our
growth is very important but
comprehensiveness of that is very
important in the sense that whatever we
make progress will be will be will be
sustained in the long run and I think in
today's world this is not only desirable
I think this is necessary and this is
possible as well given the resources
that we have so thank you very much for
her
I thank ambassador Acharya for his
statement excellencies ladies and
gentlemen I would like to introduce now
our keynote speaker mr. Justin year
Faline chief economist and senior vice
president of the World Bank prior to
joining the World Bank mr. Lin served
for 15 years as a funding director and
professor of the Chinese center for
economic research at begin University
mr. Lin received his PhD in economics
from the University of Chicago in 1986
and is the author of 18 books including
the China miracle development strategy
and economic reform and economic
development and transition fro strategy
through thought strategy and viability
he has published more than 100 articles
and referred international journals and
collected volumes of history development
and transition in 2007 he gave the
Marshall lectures at Cambridge and in
2011 the Simon Kuznets lecture at Yale
and the United Nations University wider
annual lecture in Mozambique the first
ever to be held in a developing country
his speech will focus on challenges
opportunities and strategies for
structural transformation in the least
developed countries which is a very
timely topic mr. lien we have the floor
under-secretary-general tiara ambassador
a pecan ambassador a cheerio there is an
gentleman it's a great honor for war
bank to organize this conference to
follow up the Istanbul conference and
together with the Columbia University
and a united nation and as certainly
it's also honor for me to share with you
some of my observation ideas about how
to meet the challenges and tap into the
opportunities for the distant developed
country to achieve the structural
transformation and today I'd like to
cover a few areas one certainly is the
challenges of structural changes in the
disturbed country and I'd like to
propose a framework to rethink in the
two of development economics with help
today and which are called new
structural economics and the reason why
we want to have a rethinking is because
we want to have the government to have a
better policy you know framework and for
which I call the gross identification
and facilitation in order to help a
country complete the structural
transformation and then I'd like to
point out some new opportunity arise in
this new eras of multiple across poor
damaja barbershop insured conclusions we
know that this developed country are
doing quite well
in a new era because in spite of the
global financial crisis in a last
decades the this developed country its
growth rate reach more than 5% even as
high as six seven percent and you was a
departure this poor growth performance
in the 1990s and before
however the challenges to the dis dobrze
country still huge
although globally the number of people
living in poverty declined substantially
but most of those kind of achievement
occurred in East Asian many China India
Association many India's and so on and
afforded this the dubrow country in
Africa and so on the people living under
poverty in the number actually continue
to rise and especially their fashion the
issue of youth bulge you are going to
have a lot of young people come into the
working ages and you know either society
cannot create a job for them first
they cannot contribute to the economic
growth in a country and can also be a
source of social tension political
tension in your countries but how to
achieve that
how do promote growth development in the
developing country writing abrini to
understand the nature of the growth in a
formal I see the nature of the growth of
development it's a process of continuous
technological innovation as well as
structure transformation for example
certainly all the DCI country hope to
achieve achieve someday like the u.s. we
have the modern industrial sectors
financial circles like a computer Loba
airplane was tree a war the research
institution like Colombia will hover mi
t--'s but let's look because it's
necessary for a country to have higher
labor productivity in order to achieve
higher income but even for the u.s. 300
years ago what was their production
structure
well their production structure was
aquaculture and so that the reason why
they had the fans giving and that was
very similar
to what the economic structure ended
this the developing country today and
how about a hundred 150 years ago in the
US sorry is it should be 18th century
not 16 in the 17th century important
areas the urban production was textile
was shoe making and a very similar to
that the developing country have today
and this kind of structural changes is
the nature of economic development that
is the driving force for the increase of
labour productivity and income and a
similarly in a modern time the
successful country they India now also
have a very rapid structure
transformation like a China in the 1980s
compared to the 2000 you can see the
labor force in the law of value-added
aquaculture reduce a lot endeavor force
in a higher water additive manufacturing
sector increase and within the
manufacturing sector you can also see
the crime the technological leaders from
the simple labor-intensive energy to
most of his canary but compared to the
dis developed country you can see the
structure basically remain the same
throughout the decades and and but the
issue is that for the low income country
how do they how can they achieve this
kind of structural transformation and
how can the development economics help
them to have a better policy in order to
facilitate this kind of structures of
transformation for that I think we need
to rethink the tool we have in economics
we know that development economics is a
sub-discipline or modern economics
appeared in a post-war period in the
nineteen forties at that time the main
attention was on the structural
difference between the Heinlein country
and a low-income country
and on the understand at that time was
the reason why the low-income country
could not have the similar production
structure as a high-income country was
due to the market failures so they
proposed the government you have some
kind of informational apology and I in
the you know framework so-called the
impossibly strategies but ariza what
rapport the developing country for all
those kind of approach they perform
poori and with all kind of economic
social crisis so by the time of the
1980s in own world the understanding of
the this development was because of the
government values so they proposed some
kind a neo liberal you know policy
framework in the name of Washington
Consensus proposed the government who
withdraw from the intervention and a la
marca to work and to do that they
recommended the liberalization approach
including privatization marketization
and depredation but the result again was
not very good you know it was our
instead of economic growth it caused a
lot of also crisis and slow growth and
as a result some economists think that
the 1980s 1990s were the lost a case for
the developing country and certainly
they were in this period time there were
some country economies were to Inca well
first was the very rapid economic growth
development in East Asian economy
including Japan Korea Taiwan Hong Kong
Singapore and you be looking into their
policy framework for their success was
different from the recommendation of
structuralism
instead of impossibly Sheen they adopt
certain kind of X proper motion in in
the United Aires and on world most
country were engaged in the economic
reform transition certainly China
Vietnam from
well and again they did not follow this
kind of Washington Consensus type of
liberalization
we have certain kind of gradual do you
attract approach to transform the
economy on the one hand continue to
protect some of the nonverbal sectors
but depolarize the entry to the new
sector which they can be competitive and
again so it's different from the
Washington Consensus type of policy
framework and for all these success of a
country there has something in common
that is that they all read our own
market is a basic institution for
resource allocation but at same time
they have proactive governments so the
apology framework different from the
structuralism and also different from
the Washington Consensus things that the
current two of economics cannot help us
to explain the successful phenomena and
the policy you know based on the
development thinking cannot resort in
its intended in our goal so that's the
reason why I think we need to rethink
the development economics and I'd like
to propose a new approach I call new
structural economics and a new
structural economics you know proposed
to use the neoclassical approach to
study the economic structure its
determinants and also its evolution and
a one of the economic combination if I
want to propose to use neoclassical
approach to study economic structure
them I should call that structural
economics just like if we want to use
the neoclassical approach to study
agriculture we call that aquaculture
economics to study finance we call that
you know financial economics but how
come I put a new deal it was because as
I may
in a post-war period the development
thinking at a time was structuralism and
to distinguish my approach from the
structuralism I used new structure
economics it's similar to and tokus
knows in the 1960s proposed to use neon
classic approach to study economic
institution and its determinant and he
should go at institutional economics but
because there was a institutional school
in the u.s. in the beginning of the 20th
century
and to distinguish from that he also
used a new institutional economics okay
in the best concept of the new
structural economic step
economic structure certainly we need to
understand what determine the economic
structure and its evolution in my
studying pointed that the economic
structure in a country is an endogenous
phenomenon and it depends on the
endowment structure of the economy an
endowment as economists economist we
know in our country includes natural
resources labor force and a capital was
human capital and physical capital and
for some country certainly the relative
abundance of those factor will be
different in general in low-income
country they are skills in capitals they
are abundant in the natural resources
were above was an affording ham country
they are abundant in capital and
relatively skills in the above force and
this kind of relative abundance of the
factors has a lot of implication for
economic analysis because we know the
endowments of a country in effect it's
the total budget of a country at a time
the total amount of capital you have the
total resources the top our labor force
we have north are the total
but at other country at a time in the
relative abundance of this kind of
factor of production determines the
relative prices of capital or the above
force or natural resources for
economists we know if we want to do
economic analysis two of the most
important parameters total budget
relative prices and endowments and its
structure
determine the total budget and the
relative prices of the country at any
specific time an equally important in
dominates and it's a structure can evoke
and change over time and because the
total endowment determine the total
budget relative prices Eva countries is
relatively abundant in natural resources
we know it's competitive bondage will be
in the labor and resources intensive
sectors and a similarly if a country is
very abundant in the above wars then it
will have the competitive advantage in
the labor intensive sectors any be
already bonded in capitals them award be
competitive you know have the comparable
is in a capital intensive sectors in
your developer industry according to
your competitive advantages you are the
most competitive and I buy that the
Optima industrial structure in a country
in effect termina by is endowment
structure and by the concept we know if
you want to have a higher income
certainly you need to put in move up to
the same integer structure is a hang on
country like the US now because economic
structure interest structure is in
partner to the endowment structure if
you wanted to have similar other ones
the sectors like in u.s. them you need
to have similar kept the abundance as
you know us so that means that
if you wanted to upgrade your industries
you need up radio and Dharma structure
first and once your endowments virtual
become relative or abundant in capital
you will move up to more capital
intensive sectors mejia that reclamation
energy equation is not just buying a
machine industrial operating where
require changes in infrastructure was
hard infrastructure and a soft
infrastructure we know that for the
developed country today 80 percent 90
percent of the production many in
aquaculture and a carry auto mostly by
self-sufficient farmers right and each
year after the production at the harvest
they only have a small amount of
economic surplus that they can share to
the market exchange with other people in
general they access people in the local
periodical markets nearby with people
for you know another kind of situation
they don't require elaborate
transportation system and they trade
with people who they know they don't
need to write a contract and there's no
issue account reinforcements but if you
wanted to move to the modern
manufacturing sectors the scale economy
increased so people started to produce
not for themselves but for other people
and they are not only share to nearby
market near shield their product to
national market and international market
with that you need to improve the
transportation with that they are going
to trade with other people they need to
write a contract I also need to have a
country enforcement so you need to have
a legal system and legal structure layer
and when you move to the modern
manufacturing sectors the investment new
Common increase so you need to have
financial intermediation in order to
mobilize enough financial resources
photoscan investment so that means what
we want to move from this kind of self
sufficient agricultural production you
need to improve also infrastructure was
in the high infrastructure like
transportation power supply but also so
infrastructure like a bigger system
financial system that is the nature of
structural changes in order to argue the
best way to sustain this kind of
structural changes is for each country
to follow their competitive advantages
in each specific time each day by their
department because if you follow your
competitor bandages you will be most
competitive you can generate the largest
possible economic surplus so you have
more to save the same time if you are
per your industries according to your
competitive engages the writer returned
to the investment will be the heist so
you have model safe and you will have
high incentive you see and your captor
and Tom and you can you know increase in
the rapidly as possible way and once
you're kept up a very increase you are
appear in the trees to a higher capital
intensive higher technology industries
step by step and this is the best way to
achieve sustainable growth and also
increase growth if further compared
Vantage's is a best way for the low
income country meeting honganji were
even hang on country to sustain the
growth and development but comparative
bondages is a term only understood able
to economists how to translate those
kind of principle into a spontaneous
forces in the market in a so the
entrepreneur will follow this principle
we know enterpreneur only care about
profit so if you want them to adopt
technologies go into industries
according to the country's comparative
bondages you need to have a price system
which can reflect the relative abundance
of your factory endowments if you have
those kind of price system when you have
abundant labor supply skills in capitals
labor will be relatively inexpensive
capital relative is expensive in Libya
bras can a price system named
entrepreneur for the pursue of their
profit nearby use moddable to repress to
substitute capital in their technology
they are most kind of Technology Co
labor intensive technologies they were
going to the sector which can use more
label and a useless capital north cannon
sector call labor intensive sectors and
vice versa
we have abundant capital and relative
skills in labor force and labor wages is
relatively high capital relatively
inexpensive and a bill can help those
kind of price signals named entrepreneur
for their profit never use capital to
substitute label north current
technology called capital intensive
technology never go to the sector which
can use a lot of capital and only
require a little bit of labor force
North cannot sector core capital
intensive sectors so that's reason why
and that the only institution can
perform those kind of function is
competitive market another reason why
all the successful country they have
market system is the best institution
for the economic organization economic
activity but sometime we also need to
have a proactive state as we have
observe other successful country may
have proactive state why they happen
they need to have a proactive state it
is because in touchy operating structure
changes always involve with the issue up
externalities you need to have a first
mover first mover provide information
for other people no matter it's
successful what is a failure but for the
success for the value of the first mover
they bear all the cost but for the
success of the first mover as long as
the sector you go into is consistent
with the country's compare advantages
then you are going to you know provide a
signal to other people to come in in a
competition welcome so you can see for
the first mover there's an asymmetry in
the cost of value and a indeed gain or
the success and at some time it provides
some kind of externality to other people
so you need to have a state to
compensate for this kind of externality
otherwise other people will everyone
want to wait and hear other people to
provide this kind of experiment and
without first mber you cannot have a
structure changes but also as I
mentioned these structural changes
always involve the improvement in
infrastructure was heart and soul and
those kind of improvement cannot be
internalized in the individuals
enterprises behavior so you need to have
a state to provide this kind of
coordination or improvement otherwise a
lot of structural changes may not happen
or will take a long time to happen and
you can avoid because you have the youth
bulge so we need to have a facilitating
state in order to smooth to accelerate
this process and if we need to have a
facilitation state I think to here by
Industrial Policy also is a taboo in
many corner in the world but I think
that we have and our policy would be
very important because we know that the
contents of the coordination for the
induction operating will be different
depends on what kind of industry you
want to operate to because for example
if you want to go into the sector that's
a garment
then the infrastructure requirement for
that were Bieber is different from if
you want to apply your industry - that's
a cut flower the infrastructure
requirement would be very different
that's banking in a secondly in the
government have if the government has
unlimited resources then you can improve
everything right but unfortunately the
government only have limited resources
so you need to prioritize about which
kind of infrastructure we want to
provide you need to provide the
infrastructure which can facilitate the
industry operating in your country and I
think industrial policy can help to do
those kind of coordination and a
privatization in a prioritization but we
know it's a trouble because in a pass a
lot of industrial policy field and the
reason for energy policy fail especially
under the order structuralism in for you
it was because of it's a time they were
too ambitious
in general they wanted to go to the
sector's which are so advanced the
sector which prevailed in the
high-income country very
capital-intensive but they are kept as
skills agrarian economy and under the
consideration they go against their
compare entities firm in those kind of
priority sectors are not viable in an
open competitive market she's they're
not viable they are investment and
operation required the government
subsidies and protection and those kind
of subsidies and protection not only
caused all kind of misallocation
resources can also cause rain second
rented rain second and political capture
that was the reason why the old
industrial policy fail and also based on
the new structure economics it's
desirable for the state to pray the for
see th enroll within natural policy but
you they want to be successful they need
to M
the writing in the trees before they're
operating what do I mean the right
industry for the operating may show em
in that week which are their Leighton
competitive advantages my definition or
latent compared advantage is that when
you accumulate capitals and your
competitor wanted you changes and you
should have the compare the Vantage e.e
more capital-intensive secretary embody
used to have and that is the best owner
factor cost of production because now
capital become more available Kepler
become less expensive so your capital
cost of production in a new sector
should be law so you can be competitive
but as an animation in touch equation
also required to have an improvement in
high infrastructure and so
infrastructure means we change the
supply chain Nene have a new skill
workers and if you do not improve those
kind of coordination then the
translation cost was still be very high
if translation costs are very high then
you cannot be competitive
internationally and those kind of
sectors you know it be based on a cost
of production by the factor cause you're
competitive but if your transaction cost
is too high you are not competitive
probably from we're not enter yet those
kind of sectors I call latent
competitive bondages
Malaysian compare apology is not
absorbable how can you identify those
can a sector which are not there they
are latent but they are competitive
entities for this based on the new
structure economics I'd like to propose
a framework called growth identification
and a facilitation the girl
identification the first step identify
the sector's which are likely to be a
latent compared vantage score to
identify that we know the comparative
advantages always miss comparison
compared with your past compared with
your neighbors and in my principles that
first observe countries currently the up
recurring income about tres is high at
yours they are growing dynamically
in a past 20 years look into the aggro
dynamic were in terrible sectors North
kind of tradable sectors are likely to
be your Leighton compared advantages my
main argument is that if a country the
upper income is about choice as high as
yours in the manufacturing sector except
for resources intensive agriculture
horticulture those kind of products in
the manufacturing sectors the main
concern is capital a burrow issue in a
pocket income is a good indicators of
the capital labour ratio and if the
epical income is about twice as high as
yours that means your capital
availability you allure but not too far
away and for your competitors country if
they are growing dynamically in a past
twenty years being what they are in that
we must be consistent with their compare
advantages if there are industries who
are not consistent with their compare
advantages they cannot grow in
dynamically for twenty years that's one
thing and a secondly if they are growing
dynamic early for twenty years at a
means but the other way trader must be
cheapo Co trip or even more with
increase in a wage rate they are going
to do their compared advantage in those
kind of sector right if they are losing
the competitive one is sector there are
signs that interview for them that will
be the summary interview of yours
the first step to find those lists of
potential tradable sectors and with the
Kennedys come home to exam do you have
some kind of prep enterprises already
here some kind of self-discovery and
entering into those kind of sectors if
you already have some private sectors
entering into those kind of sectors you
must have some kind of tacit knowledge
in those kind of sectors name you can
help to identify how come you cannot use
your low wages to all compete with your
competitors
what other mining country what are the
cost to make them to have higher
translate
cause so you cannot use the law
protection cause to our compete them
there can be Lego infrastructure that
can be like access to finance what do to
the constraint of skilled workers then
the government can help remove those
kind of mining constraints once you can
remove those kind of might encounter in
your firm can use the lower wages lower
production costs to all compete with
your competitors in a third state but
that
so the second step then the third step
is that well some other firms some other
sector may be totally new to their to
you you're not connected situation you
can invite a foreigner firm to come
right as I said they are losing their
competitive entities they must have the
incentive relocate their production to
other country and then you can analyze
how come they has not come yet they have
not come yet part of the mining
constraint and help remove those kind of
mining country the first step examine
the technology certainly in a modern
time change very rapidly some of the new
products some a new sector may not this
20 years ago so your competitor country
may not have those kind of sectors at
all but if you already a Sam Thomas to
you from identify those kind of
portunities and it should have market
potentials just like in the 1980's the
India's firm identified the information
services as a potential at that time
they were there on the satellite
telecommunication very expensive and
other identify the potential the India
government helped to improve the
land-based telecommunication
dramatically reduce the information cost
and I saw the information service
sectors in India you know became one of
the Delian sector in India so that's the
first step
the first step is done in a developing
country certainly infrastructure India
Nona poor most in the business
environment in aha infrastructure
certainly it's desirable to improve the
infrastructure port for nation but as I
said government resources and
capacities limited so under the canal
situation it's desirable to set up
industrial park
well industrial zone or extra precision
zone within a zone make the high
infrastructure and a soft infrastructure
good enough and to attract to encourage
foreign direct investment were normos
the investment and in the area and this
can also help to firm the cluster to
improve the supply chain to further
reduce the transaction cost and the last
one is that the government need to
provide some incentive for the first
mover in order to compensate for the
externalities but here act we say the
government incentive is mainly for
compensate for externality
so the among for the incentive required
would be very small because they should
be wobble once you help them to improve
the coordination they should be
competitive and it's different from the
original policy or industrial policy
they are you know rationale for the
government protection and subsidy is the
viability issue the unavailable so you
need to subsidize them you need to put
them and in general those kind of man
will be very large so this is the idea
across identification and facilitation
and with this we find that in the new
era of multiple girls war there's a lot
of opportunity for the digital economy
because one of the brain important
features or the multi protagoras work
was middle-income country become a rate
dynamic growth poor in the world the
middle-income country they are growing
very dynamically in middle-income
country are growing very dynamically
they provide a lot of opportunities for
the cross identification to facilitate
the structural transformation in a long
term country in any affect the
successful is the Asian economy and that
activity not only the success of East
Asian economy the success vocation up
economy in the world she's in that
revolution always follow something
codifying G's
the big goose high-income country they
equate to the high industries then the
low income country entering into the
industry like a frying geese pattern and
for that I think it's a new opportunity
for the internalization in the least
developed country because we know that
one of the very important grocer pole in
China now in a world now China India
right in a Brazil in a China today
reached the same stage as Japan in
nineteen sixties and also other East
Asian economies in the 1980s because you
can see the Packer income in China in
2009 major by purchasing power parity
was about six thousand two hundred US
dollars Japan in 1960s it's poker income
was six thousand nine hundred US dollars
Korea in nineteen eighty s is pocket
income was six thousand one hundred US
dollars and Japan started to read okay
is labor intensive in that we in the
nineteen sixties the Asian Tigers
started to relocate
they are labor intensive in that we in
the 1980s right and China not reach the
stages but the difference is that in
nineteen sixties Japan only employed
nine point seven million workers in
nineteen eighty s Korea only employed
two point three million manufacturing
sector workers Taiwan about two million
Hong Kong Guamanian in singapore harbour
million in those kind of labor-intensive
job were relocated to China helped China
to industrialize right now China reached
the same stage but the difference is
magnitude because today China employee
eighty five million workers in
manufacturing sectors in Africa both
North Africa and sub-saharan Africa
all combined today they employ about a
million workers whether this the
developed country today this 46 at least
if you are considered a they employ less
10 million workers and as I mention if
you follow the cross identification and
facilitation as I just explained it will
be a huge opportunity for the low income
country to move into the manufacturing
sectors to start the process or relocate
their labor force from the subsistence
agriculture natural resources to the
modern manufacturing sectors and that
will provide the basis for the dynamic
economic growth in your countries okay
so but let me have two additional points
although I see a lot about the
transformation from the agricultural to
the manufacturing sectors and then
gradually to the service sectors but for
the dis development country the
improvement in agriculture is equally
important because currently eighty
percent of the population live on
agriculture and aquaculture is syrup
also need to have structural changes in
technology and also in the its internal
you know cash crop and non cash crop or
those kind of structural changes and
technological changes there it's also
important it's good for poverty
reduction and it will also provide a
capital in a market for the industrial
good in other low income country are
resources rich country resources in many
country becomes curse but if you use
that where it can be operation and how
to change from cursed operation
certainly one you need to have a good
management secondly you should use this
kind of resources when to facilitate
investment in high infrastructure
improvements on infrastructure and to
facilitate the structural transformation
fundamentally us add resources for each
country but USA one of the highest
income high country so resources not
necessary to be a curse it can be a
break
similarly Scandinavia country are all
resources country but they use the
resources first good management second
use resources to facilitate structure
transformation if you can do that I
think a low-income country can grow
faster then non resources rich country
so dominant group economically Brahmin
is a continuous process of technological
innovation and structural transformation
technological innovation in your
ignition sector and a structure
transformation mean to relocate the
resources from nor very very sector to
hire body sectors and the best way to
achieve dynamic economic growth in this
the developed country is to implement a
comparative advantage foreigner
strategies and to tap into the potential
of the advantage of backwardness in the
structure in a technology operating in a
multi power a multipolar gross world
will provide new opportunity for the
least developed country to complete or
to stop and to facilitate the structure
transformation and achieve dynamic
inclusive growth in our country and
across identification and facilitation
framework as I just explained can be a
useful tool for the government to design
the inductor apology to help the private
sectors and I think that if this
developed and she can do that i'ma
competence all the countries in the
world all the district ountry in a world
where had opportunity to achieve a
person who among cross rate continuously
were 20 30 40 years and it become a
middle-income country in one generation
in a heinken country into generation
because I deep with it
in 1979 need procure income in China was
a hundred and eighty two dollars it was
less than one third of the average
income in sub-saharan African countries
less than one third
but now last year the pocket income in
China reached more than five thousand US
dollars and it's more than four times or
the average in these sub-saharan African
countries I saw it I studied inertia
with you my understanding and I hope
this new structure economics can help
that this developed country to start a
process and achieve the goal of making
the country reasonable Miller income
country in high income country in one or
two generation thank you let us give
another round of applause to our keynote
speaker
Dr Lin
you have brought a very refreshing
approach to dealing with the growth
issues or lack thereof of economic
growth of Elle disease this developed
countries we take you once again for
bringing this contribution to the
discussions we're going to have in a few
moment a second round table with expert
that we have here
but before we get there I would give you
a chance for a few comments questions to
just mean I would start by asking myself
one question that had been on my mind
during all this process presentation we
have seen that the service sector is
taking a growing share in the
international commerce international
trade if I'm not mistaken it represented
a 40 percent of the international trade
and we're talking more more about the
post-industrial era in the international
business my question would be is this
invisible for the least developed
countries to leapfrog to the service
sectors which is which brings high value
addition and quick growth income income
growth passing the industrial era the
reason for asking this question is would
the L disease be ever able to catch up
in the industrial era competition thank
you
now I would open the flow yes
representative of Bangladesh thank you
distinguished under Sec original is
indicated I do present Bangladesh and
one of the one of the LDCs and I must
thank you for every thought provoking
presentation and you said the optimism
is fully in line with the enthusiasm
that the LDC countries had shown while
framing up the IPA Istanbul programme
affection last year in May 2011 as the
distinguished permanent representative
of Nepal has indicated he was leading
the process in his capacity as the LDC
LDC chair I fully fully share your views
and I I think you are showing us the way
how to do it I have only two small small
questions one is a have you ever done
any sort of simulation on any of the
LDCs countries in line basically just to
see the applicability of new structural
approach and secondly definitely while
you are talking about economics you are
definitely putting a lot of emphasis on
the government and the market but but
there is an important sector which is
missing which is the civil society and
in a disease I would you can Li explain
why didn't you make any difference to
the potentials of the civil society
organisations thank you thank you very
much
so you have the floor would you please
introduce yourself yes hello thank you
for being here my name is Federico I'm
an economic policy student here at the
School of International Affairs and I
was wondering if you could mention talk
a little bit more in detail about one of
the issues that is important for
structural reforms technology transfer
and since we're speaking about LDCs I'm
very curious about the issue of climate
change technology transfer and not only
that but modernisations you mentioned
fbi's but I was also talking some
countries are not asking for FDI is only
they're also asking for flexibility in
international property rights
intellectual property rights so I was
wondering if you could talk a bit more
about that and they're all
multilateral Development Bank's in this
role of new technology transfers yeah
thank you we will take one more one one
more question so you have the floor and
then we will hear from ambassador of the
path you have the floor yes my name is
Sanjay Paulo I'm an economics faculty as
a result of your research dr. Lin is the
World Bank going to change anything with
its development approach thank you thank
you the last speaker would be ambassador
of Nepal I think it was a very important
speech and important study I would like
to thank you for doing that I think
there are two things that I would like
to ask whenever we talk about
development challenges and structural
transformation and lt sees you have
referred to the externalities I would
like to see how the external environment
is all for example of course you said
that you have an advantage at the late
comer but there is also disadvantage of
the late comer because you don't have
made the progress in terms of the
competition in terms of the technology
you don't have that the others has
already that advantage of the markets
already there so how do you look at the
global regime which might not be that
much supportive if it is not made
conducive to the growth and development
of their disease how do you see the role
of the external environment thank you
very much now I'm gonna give the
opportunity to dr. Lin to reply to reply
to those questions I think all these
five comments and questions are
excellent and regarding the first one
the service sectors the service in a
past before the 1980s and so on Indian
all it was non-tradable because the
improvement in a modern communication
technologies information service becomes
edible and certainly it's a new
opportunity for developing countries
but if you look into the service train
is they offer all the comparative
advantages we know that if we look into
the India's they started with course
entries it's a very very intensive now
they move to the programming certainly
it has more technology than the call
centers but in general they are sourced
that means that they receive order from
the US and they do the programming they
do you see the wages and it's a
labor-intensive process in the US you
know is in the information sector the
u.s. is in the capital-intensive
Hibiscus sectors here we want to develop
new product you need to English a lot of
capitals to come up with the concept and
the MU Souls also the program to you
know India or other country and and and
you do not know University cost hundred
millions to the brand new product any do
not know whether the market will accept
that were not yet accept that certainly
it's very profitable but if market does
not accept that that all your investment
will become so you can see the
information sectors these the
information services again is in a
follow nd compared advantage of a
country that's one thing in a secondly I
say that it's a new opportunity you need
to adapt to but it's not enough because
you also need to have a manufacturing
sectors to generate the growth and
employment if you compare India and
China other 1990s the growth rate in
India and grocery in China acquire
seminar a rich APIs and 9% but
information sectors in India in spite of
all those success in a song create the
data I saw in a past was about submit
seven minion workers directory right and
interact early I think we have an expert
here so he can answer more exactly
number writing along ten million workers
direct and interactive a worker that
create by the service sectors in China
dimension manufacturing sectors create
85 million workers so in terms of a job
and a scope for the growth I think the
manufacturing sector is still much
larger and for departing country we have
opportunity to develop information
sectors certainly I encourage the
developing country to this dobrze
country to go into that but at some time
you should not forget the manufacturing
sectors because BB the main source of
creation and also dynamic growth
secondly do I apply this grocer
identification and a facilitation to the
developing country to have some practice
and actually say yesterday we just
launched a new report called a light
manufacturing sector development in
Africa and in that report we covered
three countries one is IDEO BIA and then
Tanzania and Zambia and we are talking
with other country in Central Asia or
the African country and also South Asian
country to apply this approach you to
identify the new sectors which can help
you to have a dynamic growth we know
that in Bangladesh now garment sector
has been very successful and
pharmaceutical sector has been
successful and I just heard the printing
sectors is also successful but a poor
beggar - to get rid of poverty you need
to have more sectors and how do I tell
my those three sectors in Bangladesh you
know it come some first spontaneous and
with some government support later on
but you know unlike a common sector you
had a study 1980s and iiep in 30 years
you only have two and a half seconds
that will not be enough to generate a
job for no young people right so you
need to have 10 sector or 20 sectors in
a large country with Bangladesh and how
to
generally the other 10 or 15 sectors I
do my grocery identification of 4c
deviation will be helpful she was a
basic society I did not talk about about
that well we know civil service can help
with service delivery the civil services
already a civil society NGO and a song
can help with service delivery can also
help with some kind of monitoring and
improve in the government governance but
another thing with externality in a
coordination the civil service society
the capacity into Inza is very limited
it's the idea to get the government to
do this kind of coordination an
externality compensation in a sermon
about and the first question about
technology changes and IPR I think
further this the developing country this
is not a major issue because the sector
you enters in general mature acceptance
produce mature gets with mature
technologies so in most cases I think
that IPR is therapy issue for the
development engine only you try to enter
it into the advanced sectors which are
other new technologies then under the
kind of situation you may violate IPR
but for a low-income country if you
follow your compare advantages those
kind of high-tech sectors and now you're
compared Monti issue not go right I
would advise the government and the
enterprise not to go if they want to cut
any to receive all kind of subsidy and
protection just like in the old
industrial policy and you may need about
you have that kind of sector about a
constant further people may will be too
high so I think that the IPR should not
be many issue for the developing
countries development if they follow
their competitive Vantage's and them you
talk about the chromatic
his green technology and as our own well
if you have those kind of technology
available there in the low-income
country certainly you use those kind of
technologies there's no such kind of
technology hiding a low-income country
should also continuously develop using
the existing technologies certainly if
there are some scope for mitigation or
adaptation the low-income countries
certainly also need to log into that
kind of new opportunities but a war bank
changed well I think that I'm quite
optimistic as I mentioned you know
yesterday we launched the first project
under the ideas of new structural
economics its bravery seed outside the
bank especially in a crime country in
the Krannert country and I like it or I
do
Ethiopia government carry study our
findings and send me a legend say they
would like to implement all the
recommendations and he said that you
know the Prime Minister said this the
first time that he accept every
recommendation from a study and I wanted
to implement all the recommendation and
not only in the African country I travel
into the developing country in every
country I talked to they all intuitively
welcome this guy approach because I'm
sure all the government in the world
have the same goal wanted to develop
their countries they may do it one team
because there's no good reference and if
you can have a good reference to the
government certainly the government
would like to welcome that and the World
Bank as an institution who is the
mandate to help the developing country
and yet this kind of new framework can
help the developing country and with a
strong client demand and I can also work
I'm hopeful although my tenure will ends
in June first but I'm sure
idea will in a be a legacy to the World
Bank external environment and aware that
the low-income country can compete
adding certainly well as I mention if
you look into those canal sectors in the
dynamic growing country certainly
currently they dominate the market just
like in the 1960s friend Korea Taiwan
Hong Kong Singapore wanted to enter into
the labor intensive sectors Japan
dominated that market right and in the
1950s 1960s when chap I wanted to go
into more capital-intensive
car manufacturing sectors us fermented
receptors right how about the dimension
as long as your comparator country
growing Tara McCrory the wage rate is
going to increase very rapidly and you
have a long way to 8ns all you have the
factor cost of production advantages
your firm may not be able to compete
only because transaction consulate wahad
and if the government help you know
coordinated the Manatee the necessary
investment and an end to help but remove
this kind of mining constraints them
your firm can be competitive with your
low-cost right this has been the same
question asked in offer century but
successful country can always break into
this kind of competition because if you
go into the sector's which as I
mentioned you have later on compare
advantages then you can all compete with
your competitors so well hopefully this
bring in the optimistic message to you
thank you
thank you dr. lien for answering these
questions we're going to suspend this
session for a few minutes just to set
the stage for the next round and I would
hand over to John Wilson chief economist
at the development economic research
group of the World Bank and visiting
fellow at Columbia University is going
to chair the panel the panel discussion
in which some of the issues that have
been raised here so far will be
elaborated further by the expert that we
have whereas today he would have an
opportunity to introduce our expert
thank you thank you very much thank you
Justin I am actually a lead economist at
the World Bank
I would wouldn't presume anything
otherwise especially with such
distinguished company it's a pleasure to
be with you this afternoon